police partout justice nulle part reçu
bien digne les en état d'arrestation ne
vous donnez pas cette peine mon ami j'ai
le bras long laissons lui wade mans sont
de retour et démons pas dès lé roi démon
ont comme des arbres fort comme des
voeux la peau luisant dur
ils sont en
pour te défendre il va falloir des
hommes comme n est quelques valeureux
combattant pour te protéger
j'aimerais bien me poser au bord de
l'eau son devoir continuellement
distribuer des beignes à la maréchaussée
tout faire comme ça ils sont vraiment
pas méchant pour quelles raisons pour
battre et ils pour moi ils sont déjà
pratiquement conquis forcément discuter
le prince placé sous notre protection et
ben deux choix on va bien rigoler
il faut un peu de temps pour ajuster le
tir déjà s'il s'arrêtait de bouger tout
le temps préparez vous au combat
voilà c'est parti la peur qu'ils
inspirent fait plus de dégâts
leur nombre sinon pensez mais elle
voudrait écrasé
c'est nouveau ça entre adultes on
s'amuse comme on veut
dire que nous il faut combler
ils sont combien c'est difficile à dire
combien ton ami entends tu admires l
architecture